would you be would you say it's true
there was a plot against the president
absolutely
then we have been in an information
civil war
since trump got elected probably a
little bit beforehand nixon i was he was
spying on people in the watergate hotel
his political opponent i don't know the
specifics but this is this is so
different
it's so different we're talking about
information war yeah we're talking about
the media
lying oh this is the next level yeah
non-stop
to convince people that it's trump who
did these things
but they've been disproven trump none of
this is stuff that has
actually stuck to the president and
social media is suppressing in some
cases
the the adverb oh yes like social media
just banned people's pundit
and they like the fact that they're
putting uh it was mark levin
he tweeted electors uh the electors are
chosen by the state legislators who can
choose trump and they flagged it as
disputed
right that twitter is n does not care
about this country
and it's really creepy when you have
someone like jack dorsey say to me
he said we uh we are working for you
know rules for a global audience
yeah well guess what buddy we are an
american country i understand that you
have a global audience
in the united states your rules need to
function as per the
united states operates in our norms
right they put out i get emails all the
time
we you you know you have violated the
law and and what is it pakistan or
whatever you ever get one of those yeah
all the time yeah foreign language and
they're
but right so they're not adopting you
know to their laws there but they should
be adopting once here they're american
based
american uh you know not even
concentration but just
standards and free speech and accurately
reflecting
legal realities yeah yeah tim i've been
talking about the infowar that we've
been in for years now
and it's you know every time i have
somebody on the podcast we dig
through it we talk about the evidence
that's there how it impacts us how to
counteract it
it's everywhere and so when they've been
talking about color revolutions they've
been talking
people have been talking about this this
slow-motion train wreck that's been
happening over years
and they've been building up to this i
wonder i was thinking just
recently uh you remember how there was a
wave of leftist talking heads going out
into the media going
trump will never leave the white house
trump will never leave the white house
it was like all of a sudden they all
started talking about this is a while
back it was like months and months and
months ago
like bill maher and andrew sullivan
michael michael moore
you know they must have gotten a memo in
their little private circles to start
talking about that because they want to
start casting doubt over this whole
process
if they're going to try to if they if
there's any thought to trying to steal
the election then what do you do in the
beginning you already
discredit what a rational person would
do in the event of an
actual you know coup what would a
rational person do i refuse to accept
these results if they're tainted
and so they already sort of like took
away what the rational person's response
would be in advance right narrative
battle that's information war
so we're already thinking that that's a
bad thing but he might be doing the
right thing when he does it and they say
we told you this would happen you see
what he's doing exactly so here's the
thing
uh newsweek ran an article in july
saying that
trump would lose he would claim voter
fraud
freeze up the certification process and
then the the supreme court would kick it
to house delegations to
to vote each state gets one vote there
are more republican states than democrat
trump wins but what they do is
solid plan if right now there was
evidence of fraud
and there's quite a bit is it widespread
i i don't think so
will it change the outcome we have well
we have to we have to see it has to go
to court let's be investigated
right now the way to describe it is
we're seeing smoke
and we're seeing smoke billowing and i'm
going i'm like
hey uh journalist guy you see that smoke
there's
no smoke what are you talking about it's
right there
there's no smoke clearly you're wrong
there's clearly no fire
right that's what they keep doing no
evidence no evidence no matter how many
how many
affidavits we get they say there's no
evidence so but
just real quick the point is right now
are they expecting trump to come out
with a literal ballot and be like look i
found evidence
no what happens is you have a witness
say i witnessed fraud
now we investigate to find hard evidence
indeed and it's happening the
investigation is underway i interviewed
a gentleman matt brainerd yesterday
he's a former data chief for uh trump
for president worked on the campaign
in 2016. had a bunch of guys working
with them right now that worked on the
campaign
and uh what they've done is they've run
they bought data from all of the
relevant elect
you know electoral districts and they're
checking against
change of address databases death uh
databases requested but not returned
absentee ballots etc and they have found
through buying this data and augmenting
it and running their analysis they have
found
two million potential incidences that
would fall under these categories not
that they're
fraud but just like this is their high
risk category right and now they have
they've farmed out call centers to call
all two million people oh
and they're live and yeah they've raised
a half a million dollars to do this
and they're calling all two million
people who are tagged and
verified to verify their vote and if
they and they have
already found people who said like yeah
uh no i didn't request that ballot and
no i didn't voted it or
or whatever and they are now then they
get funneled off to
being helped filing a at first was
affidavits but now declarations
whoa yeah so matt brainer check it out
uh i did an interview with him yesterday
it's on my youtube channel jack murphy
live
check it out and donate some money if
you would like
and that is a really powerful thing that
they're doing and one thing that you
said
earlier about you know they say it's not
widespread well first i heard a funny
joke that the new
uh the new uh peaceful protest is
the you know fraud isn't widespread no
widespread right
right but it doesn't matter to be
widespread we were talking about this
earlier this is what you guys missed
while youtube was
down uh we're talking about saying
widespread fraud is like talking about
the
the popular vote it doesn't matter the
electoral college is a targeted
contest and so you're cheating would be
thus
done
otherwise you set off flags all over the
place so i you know look
do i think that there was it's hard to
accept that there could be a
you know conspiracy of people determined
to overthrow
the will of the american people etc etc
it's hard to swallow
it's possible all i know is for sure is
i want this process to play out
what i see is smoke and then i see a cia
computer program that's built to set
fire
and that drives me nuts because i can't
prove
that hammer and scorecard are being used
to flip boats all around the country
but there are people testifying that
they are no who doesn't think anyone's
testifying
what's her name or maybe that testifies
not the right word sydney powell cannot
start starting to make statements that
this software
maybe they say it could be you're
looking in the wrong direction they're
tricking you
they are getting you to fall into their
trap by talking about things you cannot
prove i can't prove it
we can prove that in nevada a poll
worker said i
saw fraud and i swear under oath so you
think it's a
red herring is not the right word but
just the wrong thing right absolute
red herring well it might be right it
might not be the point is
whenever we this is the the key aspect
of the pit trap and conspiracy theories
is dangling something sensational that
can't be proven so that everyone looks
in the wrong direction and they get away
with it and you gotta
i'm gonna drill that home to anyone
listening it's i think that's super
important
because a lot of people really want to
go hard on this
exactly it's a trick they do it all the
time you get these emails from wikileaks
and it's got this weird language in it
and someone drops in a bucket of red
meat of ridiculous
sensationalist claims and boom you get a
lunatic fringe conspiracy theory about
satanic death cults
operating and it throws off what's
actually going on
blackmail networks criminal enterprise
there's legitimate reality
that you could find in these emails but
they trick people into chasing after
things you can't prove or verify
so now you've got all these people
tweeting at me tim hammer and scorecard
and i'm like
nothing i could ever prove nothing you
could look it up nothing you could
verify you got two
you got one guy who said said a former
general saying it's true i'll tell you
what i what
i am focused on we've got now i think
what three poll workers signing sworn
affidavits saying we saw fraud
you've got donald trump filing a lawsuit
having nothing to do with fraud
arguing that there's impropriety under
the 14th amendment these are
tangible things you can actually say
that happened what's the trump uh 14th
amendment thing
the 14th amendment is that uh everyone
needs to be treated equally under the
law
simple simple way describe it under bush
v gore they ruled
all votes must be treated equally but
mail-in ballots
are completely different from in-person
voting
when a person goes to vote in person
they go through an entirely different
process
the argument there on the surface says
you've created two tracks
of unequal voting there's different
security measures
there's different so if you go and vote
in person and you mess up
too bad but if you vote by mail and you
mess up they allow you to cure your
ballot
that is not equal treatment under under
the law
now initially when it came to absentee
ballots it was for military voters
so this made sense we met an exception
we got people overseas we're not we
can't bring them back
we're going to do something and it's a
special exemption that we all agree make
sense but universal mail-in balloting
uh voting which specifically would cause
an issue in nevada
for instance which trump could use for
sure is that they just mailed them all
out
and it's a swing state and now you can
argue that a person who votes in person
chooses to get up and seek out the vote
a mail-in ballot arrives at their house
without their choice
not the same thing there's a fundamental
difference just right there
but there's a bunch of other things
they're pointing out too within the same
citation bush v gore they're saying in
this district
they said you can cure your ballot we
found your ballot was missing an address
or signature
so we contact you and say fix it but in
this district they didn't do that
therefore they've created an imbalance
and votes being treated
unequally that's trump's actual lawsuit
in uh in pennsylvania michigan
it's broad but but again the same
argument is being made
while tr while all of these people are
screaming about conspiracies and fraud
and the media saying no fraud
trump's over here filing lawsuits on
process
so that's going to be the first and this
is what vox is talking about this like
they're finally now coming out people in
media and leftist media saying
this is a real path for trump to win it
has nothing to do with these
vote tally conspiracies or anomalous
numbers
i've talked about benford's law i've
talked about how the vote totals changed
but you can't prove anything
and they're easily dismissed by saying
typo you say all of these are typos well
yeah you have
200 you know million registered voters
we have 150 million votes
you're gonna find you know a few hundred
instances of typos
irregularities yeah exactly well there's
gonna be there's gonna be a margin of
failure with
millions of people trying to tally these
votes okay fine then let's talk about
process
and the sworn affidavits and the usps
whistleblower and the weird news coming
around there
you bring up hammer and scorecard and
vote flipping you'll never prove it
and you're not going to convince an
investigator or a judge or anyone
to be like we need to investigate this
for this reason
for for hammer and scorecard but if you
go up to them and say in
this michigan county six thousand votes
accidentally glitched and went to the
democrats of the republican
trump is using that as a pretext for a
legal challenge on all of these
different machines in michigan
and they're going to file lawsuits
across the board because of it you've
got to start with something
you can prove a glitch happened we have
testimony sworn affidavit
it flipped and a republican even ended
up winning it was like a a commissioner
of some sort
he he said i was out i wasn't going to
call for a recount
then they got they called up actually he
won by a thousand votes he went oh i
didn't realize
that right there we got to get him on
the show that's all which is grounds
in it whether the courts agree here's
what i imagine is going to happen
trump's going to file the suit at the
state level he's going to say look at
this glitch
i want all of these to be hand counted
the judge will probably say
no then they'll file in federal court
and then we'll see what the federal
circuits say and we've already seen
alito side with trump in pennsylvania
they there was a four to four ruling uh
because amy coney barrett wasn't on the
supreme court at the time that said i
believe
it they they couldn't decide whether to
allow pennsylvania to extend their their
mainland ballot deadline
that right there is a violation of the
14th amendment
the fact that if you want to vote in
person you can only vote on the third
but if you want to vote by mail you can
mail in your ballot after the fact
that is a special that is an unequal uh
of votes that's messed up because you
can see what the vote is
the current vote and be like oh well
that since my vote's going to change
things i'm going go vote hey every other
ten thousand guys let's go change the
election this is why we have the back
dating scandal with the usps
whistleblower
because what according to this
whistleblower that came out through
veritas who signed a sworn affidavit and
this story is crazy
when the ballots were being collected
after election day
that he said he overheard them saying
they were back dating them to bypass
the fact that these ballots were not
applicable
so what ends up happening now is if
that's true a bunch of the ballots that
got counted after election day
actually were from after the election
which would create a 14th amendment
violation
under bush vigor i'm not a lawyer this
is just the cursory reading i did
of their argument and i asked a lawyer
and they said long
shot but possible that right there is
did pennsylvania violate a court order
by tabulating ballots without observers
fact there were observers in the
building but they weren't granted the
access the courts demanded
they counted according to giuliani 450
000 votes when people weren't uh
when people were being blocked from
actually getting within six feet to
watch the observation to observe
the tabulation those votes according to
giuliani should be disqualified and
trump tweeted about this
and this is a very very serious
challenge right now because think about
it
there's no solution here there's no good
solution it's my side wins or your side
wins
but if a court says you must allow the
observers within six feet and you say
no and count 450 000 belts secrecy
envelope pulled off discarded
you can no longer verify any of those
ballots are real you should also file a
class action suit for the people that
get those votes disqualified against the
people that did that tally improperly
that's a lot of waste of
time and civil liberty and energy i
think what what your dude was talking
about
is the is the first path yeah figure out
who these votes were from because this
is this is this period where they were
counting without
you know in violation of the court order
those are the names we need to check
because the accusation is they were
probably fake ballots or something okay
well that's easily verifiable
take the ballots we can't ver they're no
longer verifiable because a secrecy
envelope has been discarded already
or destroyed or whatever but you can see
the name of the person contact them and
say
did you cast this mail-in ballot and if
we get a decent amount of people saying
no
well then you got a serious problem so
that's step one
i don't know if we'll get to that point
and it's and i'll tell you
there is something really creepy about
democrats suing to block this
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you